TODAY'S HEARING ON THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
SUB COMMUNITY TWO ON EDUCATION
FINANCE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HERE.
CHAVEZ THEIR.
LIMON.
MEDINA. MURATSUCHI.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
SO TODAY'S OUR FINAL HEARING WE
THINK
WE RESERVE THE RIGHT TO COME
BACK. TOMORROW FRIDAY.
HOPEFULLY NOT BUT.
THAT THAT CERTAINLY THE.
CERTAINLY THE PLANTS THAT TODAY.
IS OF COURSE THE.
PROP NINETY EIGHT HEARING.
.
CERTAINLY ABOUT K. TWELVE BUT
ALSO EARLY EDUCATION AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS WELL AS
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
PLAN THAT WE I DID NOT TAKE UP.
I YESTERDAY SO THIS THE
CONCLUSION OF OF MANY MONTHS
THAT.
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING SAID I
THINK YOU KNOW FORTY PLUS HOURS
OF HEARINGS.
LOTS OF PUBLIC COMMENT SO WANT
TO APPRECIATE EVERYONE THAT
ENGAGE CERTAINLY THERE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA JOH.
HAD DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THE PUBLIC WHO
SHARED THEIR. THEIR VIEWS AS
WELL THAT'S REALLY HELP DESK GUY
OUR FINAL PACKAGE BEFORE US
TODAY AND.
AND.
WELL NADA A PERFECT PLAN WE
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE CAN BE
REALLY BE PROUD OF. INVESTING IN
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM FROM.
FOR EMMA PRE QUE.
ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION AND CERTAINLY KNOW
THAT THEIR BUDGET SITUATION
ALLOWS US TO MAKE. MORE
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS IN THESE
PROGRAMS BEFORE US TODAY.
SO WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO OUT
BEGIN WITH THE. A VOTE ONLY
ITEMS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF.
AND EDUCATION THAT.
THAT COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. AND THE SCHOOL
FINANCE AUTHORITY AS WELL AS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SO FOR
THOSE FOLLOWING ALONG THAT THE
FIRST PAGE OF THE AGENDA BUT
ONLY ITEMS. ON PAGES TWO THROUGH
NINETEEN SO THERE ARE. TEN
ISSUES LISTED IN EACH OF THESE.
ITEMS
BUT UNDER EACH ISSUE THERE ARE
ANYWHERE BETWEEN YOU KNOW THREE
AND.
TWENTY EIGHT A SUB ISSUE SO I
FIRST WE'RE GOING TO HEAR THE.
DEPARTMENT IT ISSUE NUMBER ONE
THE DEPARTMENT OF ED CTC FINANCE
AUTHORITY IS. MADE MARRIED ISN'T
FINANCE CHANGES AND THERE ARE.
.
TWENTY EIGHT ITEMS AND WE'RE
LOOKING. FOR THAT THERE
REPUBLICANS ASKED IT TO TAKE OUT
ISSUES.
SUB ISSUES TO TWELVE THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY.
SO I'M LOOKING FOR AT A MOTION
ON. MY ITEMS ONE THROUGH AND
TWENTY EIGHT ABSENT THOSE.
FIVE ITEMS
MOVED.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOMENT YOUR COULD
YOU REPEAT THE ITEMS THEY WANTED
REMOVED YET SO THEY WANT IT SO
THIS ISSUE ONE. AND THERE ARE.
OKAY HOLD ON ONE SECOND STREET
ON.
SO IT'S ISSUE ONE AND IT ISSUE
ONE THERE ARE TWENTY EIGHT ITEMS
SO WE'RE MAKING A MOTION ON ALL
TWENTY EIGHT ITEMS EXCEPT FOR.
ITEMS TO TWELVE THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY.
I'M LOOKING AT.
OKAY WITHIN ISSUE ONE ALONE THE
MAY REVISION CHANGES CARESS SO
SO NOT NOT BELOW THAT NO OKAY
ONLY THAT OKAY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM MISTER
O'DONNELL.
BUT IN THE SECOND THE SECOND FOR
MR MEDINA ON THOSE THAT THOSE
ITEMS.
MCCARTY AYE CHáVEZ.
LIMON.
MEDINA.
I MURATSUCHI.
O'DONNELL BY VOEPEL FIGHT.
OKAY
NOW I'M LOOKING FOR IN MOTION IN
ON THE.
ISSUE ONE SUB ITEMS
TO TWELVE THIRTEEN AND TWENTY.
MOVED.
OKAY MOST HIS SECOND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MCCARTY AYE.
CHAVEZ LOVE.
LIMON.
MEDINA AYE. ARE SEARCHING.
O'DONNELL FIVE.
VOEPEL.
NO.
THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SOME
TECHNICAL CHANGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY. BUDGET IN
MAY REVISE WE HAD THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. AND THERE ARE TWENTY
THREE SUB ITEMS ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
AND OUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
ASKED US TO TO TAKE OUT ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AND NUMBER TWENTY
TWO.
IN THIS IN THIS IN THIS ISSUE
SO LOOKING PROMOTION OF.
WENT THROUGH TWENTY THREE MILES
TWENTY TWO.
MOVE.
EVERY EMOTION IS SECONDS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MCCARTY.
I.
CHAVEZ.
THURMOND.
MEDINA AYE. VERSACE.
O'DONNELL. AYE POCO LIKE.
OKAY NOW I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON SET BY THEM TWENTY TWO.
MOVE SUBMISSIVE.
HE MOTION A SECOND THIS RELATES
TO. A THE WAIVER FOR TEACHER
RATIOS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY I.
CHáVEZ NO.
THURMOND.
MEDINA AYE VERSACE. O'DONNELL MY
VOEPEL.
NO.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES.
A THOSE ITEMS ISSUES ONE INTO
NEVER GOING ON TO VOTE ONLY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
FIRST WE HAVE ISSUE NUMBER.
I THINK PART OF THE CONTENT.
WE ASK.
THREE HITTER.
OKAY SO WE'RE GOING CAN NOW DO
THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS
OUR ISSUES THREE THROUGH TEN.
LOOKING FOR A A MOTION ON
EVERYTHING EXCEPT FOR ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. WHERE REPUBLICANS
HAVE ASKED US TO TAKE A MOVEMENT
ON THAT?
MOTION THE SECOND.
WITH THE ROLL MCCARTY AYE.
CHAVEZ.
LIMON.
MEDINA AYE.
MURATSUCHI.
O'DONNELL. I.
VOEPEL.
IT NOW I AM LOOKING FOR A MOTION
ON THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES VOTE
ONLY ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN RELATED
TO. THE AUDIT MANUAL.
MOVED.
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MCCARTY.
I.
CHáVEZ.
LIMON.
MEDINA I'VE.
MURATSUCHI.
O'DONNELL I.
VOEPEL.
OKAY.
THANK YOU
.
YES YOU MAY.
ALL THE.
CORRECT FOR THAT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ISSUE THREE PROTECT.
HAD MURATSUCHI THREE THROUGH
TECH.
I MURATSUCHI
OKAY WE WILL NOW PROCEED WITH
THE. PROP NINETY EIGHT EDUCATION.
A PACKAGE
WE TO K. TWELVE EDUCATION.
THIS IS THE COURSE THAT THAT
MEET OF TODAY'S. AGENDA SFAR'S
TOTAL RESOURCES SPENT.
NOT NECESSARILY IMPORTANCE BUT
THEN.
AT THIS IS THAT OF COURSE.
WHERE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REINVEST THE BUDGET SURPLUS IN
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM AND?
CERTAINLY PLEASED TO PROVIDE A
PLAN THAT.
THAT'S A REALLY ATTEMPTS TO DO
THAT.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA WHERE THAT
CERTAINLY THAT.
TALKED ABOUT FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY.
IN THE GLOBE THAT WE'RE NOT
ALWAYS UP THERE AS FAR IS
ADEQUATELY FUNDING OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BUT SAD. TODAY'S BUDGET
THIS YEAR WILL ALLOW US TO GET
CLOSER TO TO THAT MARKER SO I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE.
NOTABLE INVESTMENTS WERE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THIS YEAR.
AND I'LL BEGIN BY.
TALKING ABOUT COARSER LCF AFTER
PROGRAM AND I THE GET THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS WE KNOW.
FULLY FUNDS LCF F. IN AND OUT
FRONT LOADS THE FUNDING OUR
EARLIER THAN ANTICIPATED AND OUR
BUDGET INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED LEVEL FOR LCF AT. BASE
FUNDING WHICH WE HEAR LOUD AND
CLEAR FROM OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AROUND CALIFORNIA.
FOR A TOTAL OF THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION FOR LCF AT
IMPLEMENTATION THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO INCLUDE
INTENT LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE.
PASSED AROUND TO INCREASE THE
LC AT THAT TARGET BASE RATES.
BEGINNING IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY.
BUDGET WE THOUGHT THAT WAS AN
IMPORTANT ITEM TO ADDRESS I KNOW
MISTER MARTZ SUITS YOU BROUGHT
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S ATTENTION.
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS.
THAT WERE ALSO LOOKING TO INVEST
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
TO CREATE A NEW SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANT FOR OUR LOWEST PERFORMING
A SUBGROUP THROUGH THE LCF AFT.
ALLOCATION WE THINK THIS IS ONE
OF THE EMISSIONS IN THE FIRST.
EARLIER IMPLEMENTATIONS OF THE
ELSE IF THAT PROGRAM.
AND WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX MILLION ONE TIME
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING FOR OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
CT <c.green>.</c>
OF CREEK TECHNICAL EDUCATION AT
TOP PRIORITY FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ANNA BIPARTISAN ONE
AS WELL YOU WANTED TO MAKE SURE
WE DID TWO THINGS.
EXPANDED THE ONGOIN FUNDING
FOR THESE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
ESSENTIALLY DOUBLING. BUT THE
GOVERNOR HAD IN JANUARY BUDGET
TO FOUR HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING.
AND PROVIDING LANGUAGE THAT WE.
CONTINUE THE.
THE IMPLEMENTATION THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
WE ARE.
PROVIDING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
TOWARDS EQUALIZING SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES.
A NOT FULLY BUT PARTIALLY
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES WHICH I
KNOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL AND I
TALKED ABOUT IN A JOINT
COMMITTEE. IN THE SPRING IT'S
ALLOWS US TO PARTIALLY ADDRESS
HAT.
WE ARE PROVIDING HUNDRED.
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE AN ADD ON TO
INCENTIVIZE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS TOO MANY
OF OUR. KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS
AND FORCE THEY ARE PART DAY.
IMPACT FAMILIES AND PARENTS AS
WELL AS LIMITS.
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES SO
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
VESTMENTS.
WE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR FROM OUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA'S FAR AS.
.
SQUEEZING ACCESS THIS OVERALL
POPULATION OVERALL SLOTS AS WELL
AS THE IMPACT OF THE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES SO WE'RE. PLEASED
TO PROVIDE SEVENTY SIX MILLION
ONGOING FOR ACES PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE FIFTY MILLION.
ONE TIME FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR OUR CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES.
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR OUR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE SUMMER
FURLOUGH FIND.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO OUT ON
FOR AFTER SCHOOL EFFORTS TO.
HELP CREATE COMPUTER CODING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EXISTING AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S FIFTEEN
MILLION ONE TIME FOR TEACHER
RESIDENCY.
PROGRAMS AND WE'RE GOING TO
BROUGHT IN.
THE.
APPLICATION THAT PROPOSAL NOT
JUST FOR SPECIAL ED THE FOR ALL
HARD TO SERVE AREAS SO THAT.
A A RECAP OF OUR PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE AND.
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO.
INCLUDING THIS PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
A PIECE THAT THAT OF THE BUDGET
AND THAT WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT TWO MAJOR
PROPOSALS HERE WE HAVE. AND
ASSEMBLY I AM RESPONSIVE THAT
ONE IS REALLY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
ONLINE COLLEGE PROPOSAL. AYE
WE'RE GOING TO REJECT THAT
PROPOSAL. WE CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT
COMMUNICABLE JUST.
IRAQ CALIFORNIA ARE NOT DOING
ENOUGH WITH FLEXIBLE PROGRAMS
ALLOWING OLDER ADULT WORKERS
STRANDED WORKERS TO TAKE AYE
COURSES RELATE TO SHORT TERM.
OUTCOMES.
BUT WE DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS
A THE RIGHT APPROACH HERE
ANALYSIS SHOULD BE DISCUSSED
FURTHER IN IN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE. WE ARE ASKING OUR
EXISTING COLLEGES TO STEP UP AND
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THROUGH
EXISTING ONLINE EDUCATION.
RELATED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
FUNDING FORMULA PROPOSAL FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE.
.
WE'VE EMBRACE THIS THIS IDEA FOR
TWO YEARS IN A ROW THINK IT'S A
WORTHY. INCLUSION AS WE HAVE
DONE WITH IN K. TWELVE WITH THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
AND. HAVE A DON'T THINK THIS
PROPOSAL IS READY FOR US. NOT
PRIME TIME JUST YET RASKIN THE
CHANCELLOR AND THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS TO CREATE A MORE
INCLUSIVE TASK FORCE.
THAT INCLUDES STAKEHOLDERS.
THROUGHOUT THE FALL AND TO COME
BACK COME BACK TO US NEXT YEAR
WITH CONSENSUS AS WE DID WITH
THE LCF PROPOSAL A FEW YEARS AGO.
WE ALSO KNOW THE LOT OF COLLEGES
ARE IN TROUBLE UNDER THE CURRENT
FUNDING FORMULA WITH DECLINING
ENROLLMENTS.
SIR WE PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
ENSURE THAT ALL COLLEGES ARE
HELD HARMLESS
FROM ENROLLMENT DECLINES AND
RECEIVE A CALL AT.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
REAL ON ACT FORMULA LATER THIS
NEXT YEAR. AS EARLY THERE OUGHT
LOT OF OTHER ELEMENTS I KNOW WE
TOOK A LOT OF THE THE OXYGEN OUT
OF THE ROOM LATER THESE TWO
PROPOSALS BUT. CERTAINLY VERY
PLEASED WITH THAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE WE'RE ABLE TO.
REALLY I INVEST IN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A SYSTEM A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS ARE FIFTY FIVE
MILLION.
TO INCREASE FULL TIME FACULTY
AND BETTER SUPPORT PART TIME
FACULTY WITH FACULTY OFFICE
HOURS.
AND WE STREAMLINED TO
COMMUNICABLE IS FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS.
TO SIMPLIFY THESE THESE EFFORTS
PROVIDE MORE A NON TUITION A TO
COMMITTEE CALLED STUDENTS.
INCENTIVIZE STUDENTS TO TAKE
FIFTEEN UNITS OF PER SEMESTER
THIRTY UNITS THROUGH THAT
THROUGH THE COLLEGE YEAR AND
HELP SENSE TO GET THROUGH
COLLEGE MORE QUICKLY. WE'RE ABLE
TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION FOR INCOMMUNICADO
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
A SIX MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
FOR OUR SUCCESSFUL WHEN THEY
PROGRAM.
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME TO SUPPORT OUR.
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS ONE
IT HAD KNOWLEDGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL WILL PUT%
TOGETHER THIS PROPOSAL IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET.
SO I THAT THAT WE HAVE.
FOR OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE PIECE
OF PROP TWENTY EIGHTH.
YES SO BEFORE WE.
.
PROCEED WITH THAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE VOTES THERE WILL
BE SOME SOME ITEMS WE.
TAKE OUT HAVE SUB VOTES ANY
ITEM ANY COMMENTS FROM. A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE
DISCUSSION.
I HAVE A DONALD SO TO YOU'RE
GOING TO GIVE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THE OPPORTUNITY FULL ITEMS OFF
THAT LISTS OF JIM CARREY GREAT.
DID YOU WANT GENERAL DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE HOPE NOT MANY PROPOSAL
TO. I'LL JUST GIVE YOU SOME
THOUGHTS WE OUGHT SPEAKERS OF
THE TO THE FULL DAY CARE
PROPOSAL.
THAT GIVES ME CONCERN BECAUSE
THATSTRIKES ME AS A WANT VERSES
IN NEED.
AND THE MAY EXPLAIN WHY I'M IF
THAT MONEY IS TARGETED TOWARDS A
DUPLICATE STUDENTS THAT IS THOSE
STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST NEED
THOSE STUDENTS. WHO FALL UNDER
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP THAT WE'RE
TARGETING A NEED? BUT IT'S IT'S
JUST OFFER YOU NO LONGER SCHOOL
DAYS OF PARENTS DON'T HAVE TO
PROVIDE CHILDCARE I DON'T THINK
THAT'S. AN APPROPRIATE USE THE
MONEY SO HOPE GOING FLORIDA NOT
APPLAUD I'M NOT AS WE PULL THIS
I MUST SIMPLY. BUT HOPE THAT
FROM A POLICY PERSPECTIVE AS WE
GO FORWARD REALLY LOOK AT.
TARGETING THIS MONEY
TOWARDS THOSE STUDENTS THAT CAN
BETTER BENEFIT FROM FULL DAY
CANDOR AND DON'T HAVE IT NOW.
THEN THOSE STUDENTS WHO MIGHT
NOT.
THAT THANK YOU.
THIS ARE MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I UP.
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR.
WORKING WITH ME TO INCORPORATE
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA LEGISLATIVE INTENT
LANGUAGE.
OF FOR THE TO EXPRESS INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE.
THE LCF AT.
TARGET BASE RATE.
.
I I WANT TO CLARIFY.
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE THAT THE WORK MORE
TALK ABOUT THE BASE RATE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE BASS GRANT.
PORTION OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FOR.
CORRECT OKAY SO THIS IS TO.
IMPLEMENT.
.
THAT AT LEAST THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO. SET AN
ASPIRATIONAL TARGET.
TO INCREASE THE BASE RATE.
GIVEN THE TESTIMONY THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM.
URBAN SUBURBAN AND RURAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ABOUT THE INADEQUACY
OF THE BASE RATE EYES ACCRA
MISTER CHAIR.
YES THANK YOU WELL STATED THANK
YOU.
FUTURE MARRIAGE COMMENT ON THE
PROPOSAL. THAT I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU ESTHER MURATSUCHI FOR
BRING THAT FORWARD. AND THAT IS
TWO THINGS NUMBER ONE
ESTABLISHES HARD TARGETS WHICH
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT ALSO I THINK FOR THIS BODY I
MEAN THE WHOLE LEGISLATIVE BODY
IN THE GUT THE NEW GOVERNOR AS
WE WE HAD A NEXT YEAR. IT ALSO
SETS UP A PARADIGM THAT WE
SUPPORT LCF F. WE SUPPORT LOCAL
CONTROL. AND WE DON'T GO BACK TO
THE AGE OF CATEGORICAL SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT FORD.
EXCEPT FOR ONE CATEGORICAL WE
LIKE THAT'S THEIR CAREER
TECHNICAL I WOULD LATER. HAVE
CLOSE THAT'S ACTUALLY A NEED
MISTER CHAIR I NEED OUT OF ONE.
YEAH.
MUSLIM OF. I THINK YOU AND I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION I GETTING TO THIS
POINT AND I WANT TO THINK THAT
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE.
OF FOR GETTING US ADD TO THIS
POINT ADDITIONALLY I KNOW THAT
ONE OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT'S
COME UP WAS AROUND.
CHILD CARE.
AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
WHERE WE'RE GONNA DO THAT JUST
NEXT?
SO THEN I WANT.
YEAH.
BUT PROP NINETY EIGHT PACKETS
ANY COMMENTS ON THANK YOU FOR
ALL THAT THERE WERE A LOT AND
I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO GET
TO A A GOOD POINT I THINK
ESPECIALLY WITH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA BASE.
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE'VE HEARD.
A LOT FROM AND DISTRICTS AS
WELL AS CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. I'M SOME OF THE TOP
ISSUES NOT THE ONLYIMPORTANT
ISSUES BUT ON ISSUES THAT ARE
GENERATED A LOT OF PUBLIC
DISCUSSION.
MISS THEIR.
LAST YEAR EACH. MEMBER CHáVEZ
THANK YOU YES RIGHT AFTER SIX
YEARS.
I'M GONNA PROBABLY. PRODUCE IN A
LITTLE DIFFERENT WAY.
.
THERE IS A LOT OF THINGS IN HERE
THAT ARE REALLY GOOD THAT WE
WERE MOVING RIGHT DIRECTION BUT.
.
SIX YEARS AGO YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA WAS RAIDED.
WHAT FORTY NINTH IN THE NATION
AS FAR AS EDUCATION NOW IF YOU
WERE FORTY THREE? SO WE WE'RE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BY.
THERE SOME OF THEM MEMBERS ITEMS
OUT THERE YOU WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT WE
HAVEN'T DONE BEFORE AND THAT'S.
IMPORTANT ME FOR. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE ISSUE OF EQUITY. AND NAGS
CHILDREN THAT WERE BEING LOST.
IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T READY TO
GO TO SCHOOL WHEN THEY STARTED
IN THE FIRST VERSE DO THREE A
THREE.
AND THAT WAS INVESTMENT THAT WE
HAD DONE IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND HOW TO GET THERE.
.
ONE OF THE NUMBERS I READ THE
OTHER DAY THAT I THOUGHT THAT
WAS PRETTY INTERESTING AS WITH
THE HOPE.
GROUP LAST NIGHT.
.
THE FASTEST GROWING GRADUATION
RATE IN THE STATE IS THAT AT OUR
LATINAS.
THEY WERE GOING UP GRADUATION
RATES SIX PERCENT PER YEAR FOR
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS.
AND THAT'S REALLY SIGNIFICANT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT.
A WHOLE GROUP OF PEOPLE MOVING
FORWARD IS LEADERS WITHIN OUR.
WITH OUR ECONOMY.
.
WE SOMETIMES APPEAR WILL ARGUE
OVER.
.
A PARTICULAR PROGRAM OR I WANT
THIS SHINY ROCK BUT WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND I THINK WE NEED TO
STAND BACK LOOK AT OURSELVES.
AND HOPE THE PRESS GETS THIS IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S MOVING FOR
YOU LOOK AT OUR UP ARE YOU OUR
CHILDREN BEING PREPARED TO GO
FOR HIGHER ED.
ANY STATE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
ALWAYS HAS TWO OR THREE OF THE
TOP TEN.
AND YOU ONLY HAVE THOSE COULD
YOU HAVE GREAT PEOPLE IN THE K.
TWELVE PROGRAM COMING FORWARD.
AND I THINK THE LOCAL ELECTORAL
FUNDING TO DASH BOARD. OF THE
INVESTMENT WE MADE IN TEACHERS A
BRING IN TECHNOLOGY WITHIN OUR
SCHOOLS.
THE ISSUE OF CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES.
ALL THOSE ARE REALLY GREAT
THINGS GOING FOR THAT WE NEVER
EVER TALK ABOUT.
IN MY DISTRICT AT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS TWO POINT
SEVEN.
AND THAT'S PRETTY DARN GOOD.
AND I CAN TELL HAVING WALKED
NEIGHBORHOODS FOR THE PAST
COUPLE MONTHS.
THAT.
.
SIX SEVEN YEARS AGO WHEN I
WALKED NEIGHBORHOODS PEOPLE WERE
STRESSED. LAWNS WERE DYING AND
PEOPLE WANT PAIN IN THEIR FRONT
DOORS THINGS ARTS UPGRADE PEOPLE
WORRIED ABOUT THE SCHOOLS WHEN I
TALK TO PEOPLE THEY TALKED ABOUT
THE SCHOOLS.
WHEN I TALKED GO THROUGH THERE
NOW PEOPLE ARE MUCH MORE
SATISFIED FEEL EMPOWERED THE
SCHOOLS BECAUSE LOGAN DRAW
FUNDING.
AND THE AND THE EL CAP AND THE I
THINK THE RISE OF THE IMPORTS OF
THE PTA.
SO LOT OF THE THINGS WE'RE DOING
HERE AS FAR AS CTE SPECIAL
EDUCATION AFTER SCHOOL
SUPPORTING CHARTER'S.
EVEN LOOKING HERE WE HAVE SOME
ITEMS OUT THERE DON'T CALLED OUT
IN THAT IS THE ISSUE OF FARM
LABOR. RECOGNIZING THE LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN OUR
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES I'M
MOVING ACROSS THE.
THE ESTATE WORKING TO ASSURE ONE
OF OUR MOST VIBRANT AREAS
AGRICULTURE GO FORWARD THERE
WERE MISSING THE OPPORTUNITY OF
EDUCATION BOARD RECOGNIZING.
THEIR WORK CARE.
SO.
.
FOR THE PUBLIC THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD STUFF HAS HAPPENED OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS IN EDUCATION AND
I'M HOPEFUL THAT. THE NEXT
GOVERNOR COMES IN ALL HAVE THE
SAME SORT OF.
ARE ONLY COMES ENVISIONED AT THE
GOVERNOR BROWN HIS HAD AND AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. SO THERE'S SOME
THINGS WE'RE GONNA PLOT HERE.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE DO IS
REPUBLICANS WE GOT A VOTE NO ON
SOME.
BUT THE.
BUT THE BUT THE LARGER GENERAL
ISSUE IS IS THAT.
THIS ISN'T A BAD PROGRAM WILL
MAKE A LOT OF GOOD THINGS FOR
THE FAMILIES OF CALIFORNIA.
OKAY MISTER VOEPEL.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT I WAS
THAT.
A POPULAR ITEM FOR FOR MANY IN
OUR CAUCUS BUT WE DO FIND THE
FULLTIME COMMUNITY.
A FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROPOSAL
AS WELL SO. BUT OVERALL BEFORE
TAKE THE VOTES I WILL NOTE THAT
AND WE WON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST.
FORTIFIED BILLION DOLLARS IN
PROP NINETY EIGHT TEN.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY NEXT YEAR AND
SO. I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON
US.
TO DO IT WISELY IN AND I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW SOMEONE SAY THAT.
THROWING MONEY AT EDUCATION.
ISN'T ALWAYS THE ANSWER BUT I
THINK WE LOOK AT WHAT OUR
CHALLENGES ARE. AND OUT WHAT
WORKS
AND I THINK THAT.
WHAT WE'VE DONE NETWORK WE WE
HEARD FROM OUR?
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TALKING AS FAR AS JUST.
OVERALL MONEY THROUGH OUR LCF
FAST AND LOCAL CONTROL AND WE
WERE ADDRESSING THAT.
.
LOOKING AT PROGRAMS THAT YOU
KNOW WORK AND WE HAVE A HUGE.
.
DEMAND IN SUPPORT FOR LIKE MIKE
CTE AND WHERE DO WERE DOING THAT.
A SIMILAR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
LOOKING A PROBLEM THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT SPECIAL EDUCATION AND SEE
HOW WE CAN. ADDRESS THAT'S IN
WERE FOR ADDRESSING THAT AS WELL
SO. CERTAINLY THINK THAT WHERE
AND WE'RE STEPPING UP IN THAT
PROP NINETY EIGHT WELLNESS
FARSCAPE TWELVE AND I MAY SAY
WE'RE NOT THROWING MONEY IN
EDUCATION. FOR INVESTING MONEY
IN OUR PEOPLE IN EDUCATION SO
YES WE ARE A GOOD THING. GOOD
DATA INVEST IN EDUCATION HERE
TODAY SO WITH THAT WE WILL START
THE.
VOTES NOW IN THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE.
AND THEM.
WE ARE GOING TO THEIR IF THEY
ARE NOT ALL NUMBER IN HERE THAT
THEY'RE ALL OF COURSE. LISTED
STARTING ON PAGE.
TWENTY ONE.
THEN ON PAGE TWENTY ONE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO. TRY TO TAKE
AN OVERALL VOTES AND THEN.
THAT PULL OUT.
INDIVIDUAL. ITEMS AND SO SO FAR
WE HAVE.
THE LISTED IN YOUR INDIVIDUAL
ITEMS THAT I'M THAT I'M PULLING
OUT THERE ARE SEVEN.
ITEMS PASS THE FAR DID THE NASTY
PEOPLE OUT.
FIRST IS THE COUNTY OF.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION ARE
REGIONAL LEADS.
AND THAT'S ISSUE
WE'RE TAKING OUT THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE RIGHT TAKEN OUT TAKE A
SEPARATE VOTE.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY
EXCEPT WHEN FOR CALIFORNIA.
I THE FOOD LITERACY PROGRAM.
THE TEACHING ABOUT LABOR PILOT
PROGRAM.
THE ADMINISTRATOR PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT.
THE DIGITIZING CREDENTIAL
RECORDS.
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
A FULL TIME FACULTY ISSUE THE
FIRST DAMN SIX WERE.
OKAY TWELVE ONLY THE LAST ITEM.
IS PROP AND YATES.
COMMUNITY.
COLLEGE I THINK THERE'S ONE
THAT'S BEEN LEFT ON MISTER CHAIR
YES IT'S THE FORMER INSTITUTE OF
EDUCATIONAL LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT. PROGRAM THE FIELD
PROGRAM SO THAT'S IT.
ENDOR PROPAGATE QUE TWELVE SO
THAT WE.
EIGHT ISSUES WITHOUT SEPARATE
VOTES FOR
.
OKAY SO I'M LOOKING FOR A A
MOTION TO ADOPT THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE FOR K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
EXCEPT FOR THOSE UMP EIGHT
ITEMS THAT I AND NOTED JUST
EARLIER.
MOVE APPROVAL.
SECOND.
GAVE IT EMOTION IN THE SECONDS
AND THAT INCLUDES THE. ADDENDUM
OF COURSE
WITH THE.
.
AT LCF CRAFT.
THE.
FUNDING FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY.
MR MARTZ WOULD YOU PROVIDED US.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY BY.
CHAVEZ I LIMON.
MEDINA.
RESURGENT AYE O'DONNELL AYE
VOEPEL BUT.
I AM PASSES.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THESE
EIGHT INDIVIDUAL VOTES.
THE FIRST
.
F. THE FIRST ISSUE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION A SECOND ON THAT PROP
NINETY EIGHT
COUNTY UP. COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION REGIONAL LEADS.
MOVE.
IN A MOTION IS SECONDS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL
MCCARTY I TRAVIS NO.
THURMOND.
MEDINA.
RCG. O'DONNELL. AYE. VOEPEL
THOUGH.
OKAY.
NEXT LOOKING FOR A MOTION A
SECOND ON THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY.
INTERFACE LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY
ASSESSMENT WAS LIKE TO BE
PROPITIATED USUALLY VISALIA
CALIFORNIA MOVE.
SECOND MOTION A SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY I CHáVEZ KNOW.
THURMOND.
MEDINA AYE MURATSUCHI. O'DONNELL
AYE VOEPEL NO.
THANK YOU NEXT LOOKING FOR A
MOTION A SECOND FOR THAT FOOD
LITERACY PROGRAM.
SEARCH COULD YOU REPEAT THAT
FOOD LITERACY PROGRAM MOVED.
MOTION A SECOND WAS COLOR ALL.
MCCARTY I.
CHáVEZ NO.
LIMON.
MEDINA I'VE PURSUED G..
O'DONNELL DR VOEPEL NO.
THANK YOU NEXT LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON THE TEACHING ABOUT
LABOR PILOT PROGRAM. MOVED.
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MCCARTY AYE.
CHáVEZ NO LIMON.
MEDINA A MURATSUCHI. O'DONNELL
TYPE VOEPEL KNOWS.
THANK YOU NEXT LOOKING PROMOTION
ON THAT PROP NINETY EIGHT.
CTC.
ADMINISTRATOR PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT MOVE.
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MCCARTY I CHáVEZ KNOW.
LIMON.
MEDINA BY MURATSUCHI. O'DONNELL
GUY VOEPEL NO.
OKAY.
NEXT LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON
THAT CTC.
DIGITIZING CREDENTIAL RECORDS
ITEM MOVED.
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MCCARTY AYE.
CHáVEZ KNOW THE MAN.
MEDINA NO.
PURSUE CHIEF I.
O'DONNELL BUT I.
VOEPEL NO.
OKAY.
CRITICS LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON
THAT PROP NINETY EIGHT K. TWELVE
FIELD PROGRAM FARM WORKER
LITERACY PROGRAM PATRICIA CAN I
COMMENT ON WAY PULL THAT OFF.
YES IT DOES I'M I I WAS THE ONE
WHO PULLED THAT OFF THE FIELD
PROGRAM. THAT'S A TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GOING TO CHARTERS HIGH SCHOOL MY
ISSUES THAT OF THE CHARTER. MY
ISSUE THAT IT'S ANYONE SCHOOL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
I KNOW I HAVE SCHOOLS IN MY OWN
DISTRICT. THAT COULD USE TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
I THINK THIS SETS UP A VERY POOR
PRECEDENT. WHERE DIRECT YALLA
ALLOCATING DIRECTLY ALLOCATING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
JUST ONE SCHOOL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA?
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU.
WE ARE IMMEDIATE WE'VE WE ARE A
FULL THAT I'D NEVER VOTING ON
RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND ON THE
ITEM.
STIR DEMOCRATS AND COMMENTARY
WHITE PULLED IT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY I
CHáVEZ I LIMON.
MEDINA BY.
VERSACE.
O'DONNELL NO.
VOEPEL BY.
BUT FOR THE FARM WORKERS MANAGED
FORMED OKAY.
LAST ITEM IS THAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FULL TIME
FACULTY ITEM. MOVED LOOKING FOR
MOTION AND A SECOND SEE A MOTION
A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY I CHáVEZ KNOW.
THURMOND.
MEDINA FIVE.
VERSACE BY. O'DONNELL RIGHT.
ABOUT NOW.
OKAY
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I.
WE JUST LIKE TO STATE FOR THE
RECORD.
THAT.
.
ON THE.
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
ITEM.
REGARDING THE SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT.
THE NEW SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT.
FUNDING.
THAT ELECTED STATE
OKAY THANK YOU.
NO IT.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL.
JUST.
WE'RE SEE NOW WITH ISSUE NUMBER
TWO.
ARE.
OTHERS.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
RELATED THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE.
THIS IS THE EARLY CARE AND.
EDUCATION. PACKAGE ARE.
WE SEE PACKAGE.
RIGHT.
ONE.
OKAY THIS IS OUR E. C. E.
PACKAGE HERE AND. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE. REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT I KNOW MISTER
CHAVEZ TOUCHED ALREADY AND MISS
LEE MON WILL WILL WILL SPEAK TO
AS WELL.
WE HAD CERTAINLY A ROBUST
HEARING A FEW WEEKS AGO.
ABOUT ARE EASY AND.
THAT EFFORTS HEARING CALIFORNIA
KNOWING THAT DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. TOOK A BIG BIG HIT
AND WE TRY TO ADDRESS THAT THE
PAST FEW YEARS BUT CERTAINLY.
HAVE NOT GONE ALL THE WAY. AND
I THINK WITH WITH THIS PROPOSAL
TODAY WHERE WE'RE JUST ABOUT
THERE.
.
OVER ANNUALIZED THIS WILL
PROVIDE.
NORTH OF NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO MEET THE DIVERSE
NEEDS OF OUR CHILDREN. ZERO
THREE SIX AND THOSE CHILDREN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
A HIGHLIGHTS OF THESE YOU SEE
OUR PROGRAMS AND PACKAGE INCLUDE.
NEARLY TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROGRAM SLOTS AND THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED GENERAL CHILD CARE.
SLOTS FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
ADDITIONAL FIVE THOUSAND STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS THE GOVERNOR
ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
ADDRESSES THAT PART DAY LICENSE
EXEMPT RATES.
INCREASES THE INFANT AND
TODDLER ADJUSTMENT FACTOR AND
THE SPECIAL NEEDS ADJUSTMENT
FACTOR. A AS A BIG CONVERSATION
PIECE KNOWING THAT ARE INFANTILE
THEIR PROGRAMS ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WE NEED TO TO STEP UP. AS WELL
THAT WE PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AT ONE TIME FUNDING TO
ADDRESS FACILITY NEEDS FOR FULL
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
AND WE MAKE OTHER.
CHANGES TO REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
TO ALLOW FOR MORE READING OF
FUNDING I KNOW THAT'S VERY A
GENERIC BUT SO I'M.
THIS I THINK WILL GO A LONG WAY
IN HELPING.
BLENDS ARE.
SCHOOL BASED PROGRAMS WITH OUR
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT T.
K. AND REALLY WE'VE HEARD FROM
DISTRICTS YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
FIELD AS FAR AS WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE. EVEN WE'VE INCREASED
OUR RATES LAST YEAR'S AND ALSO
INCREASE NUMBER OF SLOTS BUT IT
ISN'T ALWAYS WORKING
AND SO WE THINK THIS WHAT WILL
GO A LONG WAY TO ADDRESS THAT
THERE'S ONE PIECE ALSO AND I
WENT TO ADDRESS THIS STARTED.
THREE YEARS AGO I THINK.
THEN ASSEMBLY BUDGET CHAIR DR
WEBER.
NOTED THAT TOO MANY FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR TKO A
BECAUSE ARE NOT NECESSARILY HAVE
THEIR BABIES BORN DURING THE
FALL MONTHS.
AND THEY'RE NOT INCOME ELIGIBLE.
BUT JUST BECAUSE YOU MAKE LET'S
SAY SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
FAMILY OF THREE OR FOUR IN SAN
DIEGO OR SACRAMENTO. DOESN'T
MEAN YOU CAN AFFORD. THE COST OF
REALLY EDUCATION AS WE KNOW.
SO WHILE WE ARE GOING TO THAT TO
THAT ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THAT BY
LOOKING AT OUR NEW AYE STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS.
AND LOOKING AT THE INCOME LIMITS
AND IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE AN ALLEY
A DOING ST PRESCHOOL A TITLE ONE
SCHOOL.
WE WON'T HAVE THOSE INCOME
LIMITS WILL TO EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY TO MAKE ONE THAT
PROGRAMS AND MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THEM TO FIND PARTICIPANTS AND
CAL UP THOSE SLOTS BUT ALSO. FOR
PARENTS AND FAMILIES THAT LIVE
IN AND IN A NEARBY. AND
NEIGHBORHOOD ONCE A VENTURE OVER
TO THAT ON SCHOOL TO BE A SLOT
FOR YOU AS WELL SO WE THINK THAT.
ADDRESSES.
THE I DESIRE OF THAT ABOUT THREE
K. FOR ALL IN CALIFORNIA NOT
FULLY THEY'RE NOT ALL THE WAY
THERE THINK THIS GOES. A
CERTAINLY A LONG WAY. I WITH
THAT YOU KNOW MISS LEE MONN
WANTED TO HAVE SOME.
WANT TO SHARE SOME COMMENTS AS
WELL.
THANK YOU CHAIR THAT I DID IT
AND I THINK THE COMMENTS TO OUR.
COMMENTS THAT WE'VE HEARD. OVER
THE LAST MONTH OR SO AND WE'VE
HAD MEMBERS OF THE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HERE
I'M TALKING AND ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE. AYE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
AND SPECIFICALLY AB ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
OUR FACILITIES AND START UP
COSTS UNRELATED TO THIS. ON PART
OF THE.
.
WHILE THIS BUDGET AND OTHER
BUDGETS.
HELP US GET
TO A BETTER PLACE AND THEY DON'T
HELP US MEET THE NEED THAT IS
OUT THERE.
OR MEET THE FULL NEED.
THAT IS OUT THERE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE SLOTS ARE MINIMAL. ON SLOTS
ARE VERY MUCH NEEDED AND WE HOPE.
THAT I IN A TIME WHERE.
WHERE THERE'S A LOW BUT THERE'S
A LOT OF? A LOT OF GREATER NEEDS
AND WE DON'T FORGET THAT THE
INVESTMENT WE MAKE VERY EARLY ON
AND THE FACT THAT THE STATE. IS
IN A PLACE WHERE THEY'RE WORKING
WITH A SURPLUS AND WE MAY NOT BE
HERE YEAR AFTER YEAR ON THIS IS
A TIME. A TIMELY MATTER IN
MAKING THIS INVESTMENT NOW.
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD I AM NEEDS
IN OUR STATE.
THANK YOU. AND THAT WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS A CONTINUED CONTINUED
AFTER THE ASSEMBLY.
WHERE WE'RE WORKING ON A BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION TO LOOK AT OUR
E. C. E. NEEDS I'M?
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS FINANCING
NEEDS AND WHA'S.
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT FOR OUR.
OUR KIDS IN CALIFORNIA SO WE'LL
BE A LOOKING AT THIS THAT PASSED
TODAY AS WELL AND ALSO NOTE THAT
WE HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR COMING IN.
NEXT YEAR AND CERTAINLY PLEASE
THAT WE WATCH THE DEBATES THIS
IS.
A TOPIC FRIEND CENTER FROM
ARGUMENTS OIL CANDIDATES.
LEAST MAJORITY OF THEM.
AM I KNOW HERE IF YOU ARE
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR MISTER
CHAVIS HE BE TALKING ABOUT THE
C..
OKAY SO I WAS TOLD YOU LET THE
OTHER DAY I WISH I'D BEEN IN
THAT DEBATE.
ALRIGHT SO SO WITH THAT.
.
WE WILL LOOK FOR A MOTION ON THE.
E. C. E. PACKAGE.
SOME LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON THE
ENTIRE PACKAGE EXCEPT FOR WERE
PULLING OUT.
A FOR NOW THE FUNDING FOR THE
BALDWIN PARK.
LITTLE BY LITTLE SCHOOL
READINESS PROGRAM
SO THE LOOKING FOR MOTION THE
ENTIRE PACKAGE.
SECOND.
ABSENT THAT ONE NIGHT AND WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY AYE CHáVEZ AYE LIMON.
MEDINA AYE. MURATSUCHI AYE
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
OKAY LOOKING LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON THAT.
BALDWIN PARK LITTLE BY LITTLE
SCHOOL READINESS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MOTION AND THAT.
SECONDS.
THE OTHER PROBLEM YES SIR GOODS
GO BACK.
IT'S ABOUT HEALTH.
YEAH I THOUGHT WE WERE.
VOTE IN THAT LAST VOTER YEAH
HOLD WHEN PART IN TO SOUND QUITE
RIGHT BUT I DON'T KNOW OKAY I
WOULD LIKE CHILLS MIGHT DO WELL
TO MELLOW HIDING. IN HIS IS THE
ETHIC AYE FOR THE EASY PACKETS
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL.
YES.
AND NOW WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND FOR THAT BALDWIN PARK
LITTLE BY LITTLE. SCHOOL
READINESS PROGRAM. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MCCARTY I CHáVEZ KNOW.
LIMON.
MEDINA ARE.
PURSUE CHIEF AYE O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL NO.
OKAY. THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES
THAT SECTION WILL NOW.
PROCEEDS TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
ONE QUICK SECOND
OKAY WILL THAT.
GET BACK TO BUSINESS HERE.
OUR LAST.
ITEM OF THE DAY RELATES TO THE.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THING
WE'VE TOOK UP THE.
OTHER HIGHER EDUCATION PIECES
YESTERDAY AND TODAY.
WE'LL BE.
DEALING WITH THE UC SYSTEM.
OKAY.
SO.
A QUICK SUMMARY OF THE OF THE
YOU SEE PACKAGE ONE THAT WHERE.
A VERY ARE PROUD OF AS WELL
DISLIKE THE CSU PACKAGE AS WELL
AND. FRANKLY IT'S NOT.
STAR DESIRE WE HAVE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO DO WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO DO WHICH IS PROPERLY FUND
HIGHER EDUCATION CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVEN'T ALWAYS HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY. AND SO THIS YEAR
SUBCOMMITTEE PROVIDES A ROBUST.
THAT PACKAGE BUDGET PACKAGE FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND FRANKLY WE PROVIDE MORE
FUNDING THEN THE UNIVERSITY
ASKED FOR DEALING WITH THEM AND
NEEDS AND ISSUES THAT WE ARE ARE.
ARE BUT MOST PRIORITY FOR OUR
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WHICH I'LL GET TO IT IN A BIT
HOW WE THINK WE'VE GOT COME TO
AN AGREEMENT. ON MAJOR
COMPONENTS OF THIS PACKAGE WITH
A STUDENT STAKEHOLDERS IN THE UC
AND OVERALL.
A HUGE WIN FOR OUR.
FOR OUR STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND FOR THE UC SYSTEM THE
FLAGSHIP RESEARCH UNIVERSE IN A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU SEE WILL RECEIVE A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN MILLION ONGOING
FUNDING ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET.
THIS FUNDING WILL SUPPORT TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED MORE UNDERGRADUATE
AND GRADUATE.
SPOTS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT
WAS PART OF OUR LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AGREEMENT.
AS WELL AS TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL SLOTS.
TWENTY NINETEEN.
TWENTY TWENTY WE KNOW THAT WE
WHEN WE GOT HOME TO OUR
DISTRICTS THIS IS. A TOP ISSUE
THAT WE HEAR. ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T CLOSE THE DOOR HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION SEWER. ARE PROUD OF
OUR EFFORTS TODAY DEFINES I
INCREASE ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE TAKING CLASS
TAKING CLASSES TAKE AN EXAM
SITTING ON THE FLOOR.
.
DEALING WITH OVER ALL OVER
ENROLLMENT YOU SEE OVER AND
ROLLED.
STUDENTS LAST YEAR'S WHICH I
GUESS IS A GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE
DEALING WITH THAT WOULD ACCESS
BUT TO WITH THAT COME SOME.
SAM SAMBA SOME STRESS AND SO.
WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND
WE'RE WORKING ON AND.
A MUTUAL PLAN HERE THAT WE'RE
LAYING OUT A PARTNERSHIP. WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
UC TO ADDRESS THIS.
TO ADDRESS THIS OVER AND ROMANCE
AND THE UNDERLYING. ISSUES WITH
THEM WITH OVERCROWDING.
SO WE'RE PROVIDING TWELVE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO SEND
DIRECTLY TO CAMPUSES TO.
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
AND.
WERE ADOPTING BUDGET LANGUAGE.
.
EXPECTING YOU SEE
TO DO THE WORK WITH A WHICH THEY
HAD OUTLINES IN THEIR REGIONS
WORK PLAN DEALING WITH THEIR
AUDITS.
HOT EFFORTS IN IDENTIFYING A
SAVINGS WITH EXISTING RESOURCES
THROUGHOUT THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT THE UC SYSTEM. AND.
AT HOUSE THOSE SAVINGS TO
MATERIALIZE.
THAT ASKING YOU SEE TO DIRECT
THOSE RESOURCES BACK TO THE
CAMPUS IS TO SUPPORT STUDENTS.
AND THAT AND EFFORTS AT AT THE
AT THE WHOLE NINE CAMPUSES
DEALING WITH I'M. OVER THE
ROMANS AND.
AND CROWDING ISSUES.
SO WE'RE CERTAINLY ARE THOSE
ARE THE TOP TOP ISSUES THAT WE
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR THIS THAT
THIS YEAR'S SO. GLAD WE HAVE AN
ACCORD ON THAT. OTHER MAJOR
CRITICAL ISSUES OF THIS PACKAGE
INCLUDE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME.
IN PROP TO FUNDING AND TO HELP
DEAL WITH THE UC PENSION A
LIABILITY.
WE PROVIDE AN OUTLINE. ANDA
HOPEFUL SOLUTION TO ALLOW THE UC
PATH PROJECT TO STAY ON TRACK TO
BE IMPLEMENTED. THAT WE WE
IMPROVE THAT TRANSPARENCY IN
PROVIDED EXTRA FUNDING FOR
STUDENT HUNGER.
AND FACULTY DIVERSITY AND
PROVIDE FUNDING ARE FOR RESEARCH
IN CRITICAL AREAS FACING THE
STATE'S
FROM OPIOID ADDICTION TEALA TO
GUN VIOLENCE TO. VALLEY FEVER
A FOCUSING ON ACCESS AS WELL WE
ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT WAYS THE UC
CAN EXPAND SATELLITE CAMPUSES TO
TO HELP. ADDRESS ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AND TO EXPAND THE THE UC
FOOTPRINT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
SO WE SUPPORT ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR THE UC DAVIS PLAN. FOR THE
AGGIE SQUARE PROJECT WHICH IS
GREAT NEWS FOR THE UC DAVIS A
CITY SACRAMENTO. ARE OUR
STUDENTS IN IN CALIFORNIA. AS
ALLOW DAVIS TO HAVE MORE ROOM TO
ENROLL MORE.
CALIFORNIANS AND HELP WITH THE
ECONOMIC FOOTPRINT HERE AT THIS
END AND THE REGION OF THE STATE
CAPITOL. A SO WITH THAT THAT'S
THE OVERVIEW OF THE YOU SEE
BUDGET PACKAGE BEFORE WE TAKE
THE VOTES OPENED UP TO. TO US TO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MR MEDINA.
I'D LIKE TO FIRST THANK.
ARE CHAIR MR MCCARTY FORGETTING
IS HERE.
A TO A POINT WHERE I THINK FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
IN MY YEARS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE ARE FUNDING A
HIGHER EDUCATION AT THE LEVEL
THAT WE SHOULD BE. SO I THANK
THE CHAIR FOR THAT.
ALSO WANNA THANK THE STUDENTS
WHO ARE NOT HERE TODAY BUT HAVE
CERTAINLY BEEN EVERYWHERE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE WHETHER WAS HERE
IN SACRAMENTO OR WHETHER IT WAS
OUR HEARINGS. I END AT FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE OR AT UC RIVERSIDE
WHERE WE SAW. A STUDENT AFTER
STUDENT.
SPEAK ON ON THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO FIND
HIGHER EDUCATION. WERE THE
STUDENTS WON'T HAVE TO BEAR THE
BURDEN OF CONTINUING TO RAISE
HIGHER TUITION.
SO AYE I THINK IT'S A A GOOD
FIRST STEP AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
OTHER YEARS WHERE WE CAN
CONTINUE. TO FUND HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT AT THE LEVEL
WHERE IT SHOULD BE.
OKAY.
MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU I ALSO.
WATCH A THANK CHAIRMAN CARTY FOR.
HAVING SOME.
.
YEAH. LAST MINUTE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BUDGET PACKAGE.
.
AS A ARE PROUD CAL BEAR IN UCLA
BRUIN NINE.
VERY HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO MADE
THE UNIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA'S
FULL FUNDING REQUESTS.
WITHOUT INFRINGING ON THEIR
CONSTITUTION AUTONOMY.
.
I.
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
I APPRECIATE BE.
.
PHONE CALLS THAT I RECEIVED FROM
A. UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENT JANET NAPOLITANO AS
WELL AS.
GEORGE KEY FOR THE CHAIR OF THE
BOARD OF REGENTS.
.
AND.
I JUST WANT TO AND WITH THE.
KNOW THAT.
WHILE THIS THE GOOD BUDGET YEAR
AND THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO FULLY
MEET THE UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA'S
FUNDING REQUEST.
THAT.
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR ME IS IS
THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE MAXIMIZING TAXPAYER DOLLARS
TO. TO BE SPENT ON INCREASING
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
AND LESS MONEY TO BE SPENT ON
ADMINISTRATION. AND.
AYE WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
THAT PRINCIPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
.
WORKING TO THIS A VERY GOOD
BUDGET PACKAGE.
I THINK AN ECHO THE THINKS TO
ARE CHAIR.
AND TO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THAT MEANING GATES
I THINK IT'S REFLECTIVE OF. WHAT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MEANS I TO OUR STATE BUT ALSO TO
THE STUDENTS I'M WHO ARE ALUMNI
WHO GO TO THIS AT UNIVERSITY? IE
THAT.
YOU KNOW I I HAVE AND I THINK I
THINK THAT THE BUDGET IS
REFLECTIVE UP OR. AT LEAST THE
ASSEMBLY IS PROPOSAL IS
REFLECTIVE OF OUR INTEREST IN
TRYING TO BUY.
ENSURE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S UMBILICAL FOR MORE
STUDENTS AND FROM OUR STUDENTS
IN OUR STATE. AND I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WHILE WE WANT TO
CONSIDER.
ENDING WE DO IN THIS BUDGET
DEFINITELY DOES INCREASE.
AND THEY HAVE TARGETS FOR
ADMISSION GROWTH AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF STUDENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHOSE
NEEDS.
ARE SUCH AND THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO NOT LOSE SIGHT OF
NOT JUST PROVIDING SPOTS BUT
ALSO A QUALITY EDUCATION.
AND I THINK THAT WE ARE GETTING
THERE I THINK THAT CALIFORNIA.
IS WORKING HARD AT THIS IS A
GOOD YEAR.
IT MAY NOT BE A GOOD HERE IN THE
FUTURE SO I GO BACK TO WHAT'S
BEEN SAID IN PRIOR COMMITTEES.
ABOUT THE NEED TO THINK TO HAVE
A LONG TERM VISION AND
UNDERSTAND THAT WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE AS A STATE TO MAKE THIS
LEVEL OF INVESTMENT EVERY SINGLE
YEAR. AND WE WILL HAVE.
HERE.
AND SO I HOPE THAT THIS
INVESTMENT.
THIS YEAR ID INVESTMENTS WE'VE
MADE IN THE PAST AND THE
COMMITMENT TO TRY TO.
INSURE WORK.
OPENING SPOTS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WERE OPENING SPOTS.
FOR PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
.
AND IS TRYING TO DO BETTER ABOUT
MEETING THE NEEDS OF CURRENT
STUDENTS ISN'T LOST WHEN THAT
WHEN. I'M IN A HALF I HATE TO
SAY BUT WHEN THE TIME COMES AND.
CALIFORNIA'S I FISCAL OUTLOOK
IS IS A DIFFERENT REALITY THAT
WHAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING NOW.
JEFF JARVIS.
YOU I KNOW THERE'S A LOT A
STATEMENT CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ECONOMY IS DOING WELL IN THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE ECONOMY
SHIFT IN THE FUTURE.
AND.
BUT. I WON'T BE HERE BUT A
CAUTION I WOULD SAY IS THAT
WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT GAINS IN
EDUCATION. AND THE PAST SIX
YEARS.
WHEN BUDGETS ARE SET OF
PRIORITIES.
AND I WOULD STRONGLY RECOMMEND.
EVEN IN A HARD TIME COMING IN
THE FUTURE WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO INVEST. IN EDUCATION BECAUSE
WE ALL KNOW THAT EVERY STUDY
SHOWS THAT. INVESTMENT EDUCATION
RETURNS A FIVER SEVEN FOLD
RETURN IN THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE.
MAKE MONEY AND HIGHER QUALITY
OF LIFE.
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS WE DO.
ACROSS THE BUDGET.
MET.
THE VAST MAJORITY IN ON HER
DON'T HAVE THAT RETURN.
SAU JUST ASK YOU TO. CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN EARLY CHILD EDUCATION
KATIE TWELVE CHANGES.
OUR CD <c.green> OUR COMMUNITY</c>
COLLEGES BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY
WAY WE'RE GONNA GROW THE ECONOMY
AND DEAL EQUITY ESPECIALLY FOR
CHILDREN. OF COLOR COMING FROM
REALLY STRESSFUL ENVIRONMENTS
SO I'D HOPE THAT WE.
IN THE FUTURE WE DON'T BACK DOWN
ON EDUCATION I WOULD SAY GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE BUT DON'T.
THIS COMMITTEE SAID TO I WOULD
SAY AND INNER.
A VERY STRONG WAY SETS.
THE PRIORITY OF THIS STATE
BECAUSE IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN
THE PEOPLE.
WELL THANK YOU AND THAT BEFORE
MY PARTING.
YOU SEE COMMENTS THIS WHEN IT'S
TO TELL YOU MISTER CHáVEZ THANK
YOU FOR YOUR. FOR YOUR EFFORT
FOR THE PAST SIX YEARS I KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE VICE CHAIRS ARE ON
THIS COMMITTEE. BUT DONE BUT I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN HERE UNDER ON A
FEW CHAIRS MISTER AMMAR CG
MYSELF AND YOU'VE BEEN THAT KIND
DE FACTO VICE CHAIR. AND THAT WE
WORKED IN A VERY BIPARTISAN
MANNER AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF
THAT PROUD THE VOTES BECAUSE IT.
A SOLICITS I'M YOUR INPUT TO
WORK ON THESE THINGS IN A IN A
BIPARTISAN FASHION SO.
HI ALL I I DO APPRECIATE THAT
AND AND JUST ON A GO OVERALL
BEFORE THE FINAL VOTE ON THE UC
PACKAGE.
I WILL NOTE THAT.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIANS.
COUNT ON THIS.
THIS SEGMENT FOR OUR ECONOMY
BUT ALSO.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE NEXT GENERATION
AND.
.
IT'S SOMETHING WE BUDGET IN THAT
DRUM BEAT EVERY YEAR IS
EXPANDING MORE SLOTS IN DEALING
WITH ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIANS.
WE WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THE
NON RESIDENT ISSUE THIS YEAR.
CERTAINLY PROUD DATA.
COUPLE YEARS AGO WE BANGED ON
THIS PRETTY HARD AND.
GOT THE UC REGENTS TO ADOPT THE
POLICY SETTING A CAP.
AND REALLY A RATIO AND A SILLY
CAPITA RATIO FOR EVERY SOME OF
STUDENTS THAT YOU ENROLL
INTERNATIONAL YOUR OUT OF STATE
YOU HAVE TO ROLL.
DEPENDS ON THE CAMPUS YOU
NEITHER FOR FIVE CALIFORNIANS
WHICH WE THINK WE SHOULD
PRIORITIZE OUR OUR. OUR SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIANS I WILL NOTE THAT
OVER IN THE SENATE THEY ACTUALLY
TOOK AN ACTION TO GO EVEN
FURTHER THAT WE DID SO.
SITE IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE.
HOW THAT'S GOING TO MATERIALIZE
IN THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE BUT
THE ISSUE CERTAINLY ALIVE AND
WELL IT ALL BOILS DOWN TO ACCESS
TO?
OUR OUR UC SYSTEM OFFER FOR
THEIR YOU KNOW FUTURE
GENERATIONS ITSELF.
OUR PACKAGE HERE TODAY AS A
MISTER I'M MEDINA SAYS THAT
THERE'S THAT AND GRANTED OUR
PACKAGE HAS WITH THE
CONFISCATING HIM AND THE
GOVERNOR. HASN'T SUCCEEDED YET
THAT DAMN THEY DAY SUPPORT THIS.
BUT THEN YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT'S
OUR STEP IT'S OUR MARKER FROM
THE ASSEMBLY AND OUR VALUES FOR
HOW WE. THINK ABOUT HIGHER
EDUCATION CSU MENU SALUTE TODAY
OF COURSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ABOUT YOU SEE.
SO ONE. I WITH THAT.
LOOKING FOR A ARE A A MOTION ON
THE ENTIRE AYE YOU SEE PACKAGE.
EXCEPT FOR WE ARE PULLING OUT
FOR NOW I'M A FEW ITEMS.
PULLING OUT ISSUE NUMBER NINE
RELATE TO.
SUPPORT FOR THAT.
FOR THE PENSION FUNDS.
.
WORK FALLING OUT ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN RELATED TO.
YOU SEE.
EMPLOYEE DATA.
PULLING OUT ISSUE SEVENTEEN TO
RESEARCH FOR SUGAR.
ITEM EIGHTEEN LEAD TO.
RESEARCH.
GUN VIOLENCE.
AND I'M.
I AM TWENTY RELATE TO ONE TIME
SUPPORT FOR ANTI BIAS TRAINING.
AND ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
RELATED TO.
ONETIME SUPPORT FOR THE
INSTITUTE ON GLOBAL CONFLICT AND
COOPERATION.
LOOKING FOR A MOTION A SECOND ON
THE ENTIRE YOU SEE PACKAGE. APPS
IN THOSE ITEMS.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MCCARTY AYE
CHáVEZ.
I LIMON.
MEDINA.
WE'RE SEARCHING.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
AND ARE MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
RIGHT OKAY WOULD TAKE IN A VOTE
ON THE. TIRE THERE ARE REMAINING
ITEMS OKAY SO THAT WAS WILL BE
ITEMS NUMBER. AND NINE ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY ONE.
THE MOTION A SECONDS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MCCARTY AYE.
CHAVEZ NO.
LIMON.
MEDINA.
MURATSUCHI.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
OKAY I KNOW WE TOOK A LOT OF
VOTES TODAY SO IF ANY.
MEMBERS.
HAVE ANY FINAL QUESTIONS ALL
HOLD THE AYE ROLL OPENS IT TO
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE IF
YOU LIKE TO AS WELL SO. I WOULD
THAT JUST WANT TO THANK.
EVERYBODY FOR PARTICIPATING
THIS YEAR.
ALL THE WITNESSES I'M
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELIA THINK
YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. POT THANK YOU TO
OUR SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FEAR.
FEAR ATTENDANCE I WILL GIVE THE
A PLUS THE WORD.
FOR ATTENDANCE TO AYE MR VOEPEL
PIZZA SO THANK YOU FOR IRAQ.
MOVING HERE MOUTH.
.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN FOR ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN